[Musique]
5 trucs à retenir sur la crème solaire
mettez-en toutes les deux heures et
après chaque baignade et à chaque fois
que vous avez beaucoup transpiré une
couche épaisse sur toutes les zones qui
vont être exposées en minutes avant
d'aller au soleil même si vous êtes à
Londres parce que les UV se réverbère
sur un certain nombre de surface comme
l'eau ou le sable par exemple
souvenez-vous que l'écran total c'est
quelle que soit l'indice de protection
il y a toujours un peu du V qui passe
d'ailleurs l'appellation écran total
elle est interdite choisissez votre
indice de protection en fonction de la
nature de votre peau plus elle est
claire moins vous avez de
photoprotection naturelle plus il vous
faut un indice élevé sachez que les
crèmes indiquent 6 filtres 84% des UV
les indices 25
96% et les indices 30 et 50
respectivement 97 et 98%. les indices
annoncés concernent les UV B c'est à
dire ceux qui donnent principalement les
coups de soleil mais les UVA provoquent
aussi des cancers de la peau donc
demandez une crème qui filtre les deux